scp-682 the indestructible reptile  versus scp-1237 the epsilon wave who  would win  scp-1237 is a brain pattern occurring in  deep rem sleep that allows an  individual's dreams to shape and affect  reality when they wake one specimen  affected by scp-1237 was permitted to  observe scp-682 and was instructed to  dream that scp-682 was a small house cat  with no anomalous abilities and that the  foundation had successfully terminated  it seven seconds into their sleep the  subjects seized violently and died less  than a minute later alongside 13 other  observing security personnel their  bodies were covered with scratches and  bites as well as symptoms of  toxoplasmosis and bubonic plague inside  scp-682's chamber was a small house cat  licking blood from its coat of fur it  regenerated into scp-682 only a few  hours later looks like in this matchup  the lizard not the cat got the  foundation's tongue as expected